[Spooky music]
[Pained sigh]
"I'll always be with you, Mark."
"You're not gonna die 'cause I won't let you."
"Mark, I know you're hurting, but please don't shut me out like this."
"She's coming back."
"She's gonna come back."
(Boy screams)
"Henry. Come on down here."
"Here. Made two of 'em. So we could be brothers."
(Mother)
"Oh, wow. As if one wasn't enough."
[Silence]
"Mark? You understand, don't you?"
"I'm leaving you now, so I..."
"So I never have to leave you again."
(Mother, chuckling)
"Whoa, whoa,  whoa... not so fast."
"How about some breakfast?"
"Sleep okay last night?"
"Yeah."
(Nostalgia Critic)
Good times, good memories, good gracious, what a day.
Folgers: Partaking in every artificial moment.
"Go on."
"They give you cancer."
"Who cares? You're gonna die anyway."
(clucking)
"Joey's in a jam. What should he do?"
"Uh, Kate."
"Get a teacher!"
"Excellent!"
"Get out of there!"
"You got it. Let's see if Joey's that smart."
(Indistinct yelling)
"What'd your mom look like the last time you saw her?"
"Kinda pale."
"Kinda pale..."
"I took a real good look when my kid brother, Richard, drowned in the bathtub."
"Your brother drowned?"
"He was completely blue."
"You should'a looked at her eyes and her lips..."
"and touched her skin to see what it felt like."
"Don't hit her. Just give her a scare."
"What a great shot!"
"Yeah..."
"but the sight's not right yet."
[Pained sigh]
"Yeah..."
"but the sight's not right yet."
[SFX: evil, maniacal laughter]
"Today was fun."
"Tomorrow will be even better."
[Evil, maniacal laughter]
"If I let you go... you think you could fly?"
"Oh, you know, I spoke with Alice Stavenport this morning."
"Oh, she's a therapist who works with Wallace..."
"Right."
[Evil, maniacal laughter]
"Because when you make a promise..."
"when something's your fault..."
"What did you do?"
"I let someone die."
"No!"
"GANDALF!!!"
"NOOO!!!"
"Mark?"
(Nostalgia Critic)
Can't sleep? Helping your nephew deal with dead mother issues?
At least you're wearing a robe from Sears.
(Nostalgia Critic)
Making boys think their mothers have come back from the dead everyday.
Do not worry, Culkin. Their love will be their downfall. (Evil chuckling)
"Try to hit that sign."
"Negative."
"Targeting..."
(Dog whines)
"I was only trying to scare 'em."
"Don't worry, Marv. I'll get him for ya."
"HARRY!!!"
"Who is he?"
"This is Mr. Highway."
"Wow."
"Keep the change, you filthy animal."
"Go ahead. Tell 'em."
"Or better yet, why don't we tell 'em together?"
" 'It was Mark, Dad. He talked me into it.' "
"Dad! Mark has something to tell ya!"
"What is it? What's wrong with Mark?"
"I don't know. He's been acting pretty weird."
"I better go so if he's okay."
[Evil, maniacal laughter]
"I told my dad I'd see if you're okay."
"Well... are you okay, Mark?"
"Guess what! Mom says we can go skating tomorrow."
"Connie?"
"What did I tell you about coming into my room?"
"You guys weren't working or anything."
"You didn't answer my question, so I'm going to have to do it for you!"
(Girl cries)
"You're not allowed to come into my room."
"OW!"
"Not now, not ever!"
"Never!"
"You're wrong about that!"
"It's now my room, too."
"Mom! Mom! They're fighting!"
"You like my sister, don't you?"
"Such a sweet, little girl."
"Too bad if something were to happen to her."
"If she got hurt, you'd be sad, wouldn't you, Mark?"
"Hey... accidents will happen."
"Boy! Boys! Henry! What's going on?"
"I'm sorry, mom. We were playing this really dumb game."
"We weren't fighting. We're just playing."
"Weren't we, Mark?"
"Yeah... playing..."
"Well, alright, but just not so rough, okay?"
"I mean you two looked like you were trying to kill each other."
"Change or you'll die in the story, Mark."
"What are you doing?"
"I wanna tuck in my kid sister."
[SFX: booing audience]
"Such a sweet little thing."
"Do you really think I'd hurt her?"
"Yes."
"What do you think this is, a game?"
[Random sounds of miscellaneous violence]
(Echoing)
"Change."
"I don't think what happened at the pond was an accident."
"Wha- What do you mean?"
"Connie didn't just slip."
"You don't know what he is!"
"Henry tried to kill Connie and he could do it aga--"
"Stop it!"
"Stop it! That's a lie!"
"Stop it! Stop it! That's a lie!"
"Mark!"
(Echoing)
"Change..."
"Hi, Mark."
"HOLY HELL!"
"He scares me sometimes."
"What does he do?"
"Please don't ask me that. I can't tell you."
"Why not?"
"Because Mark's my friend."
[Alarm blares]
"Hey, Mark!"
"Don't fuck with me."
[Crunch]
"You wouldn't..."
"Wouldn't what?"
"Hurt her."
"Your mom, my mom... what the hell?"
"I'll kill you, first."
"Poor Mark... so violent."
"Use your aggressive feelings, boy."
"Let the hate flow through you."
"What happened the night Richard died?"
"I was downstairs, playing."
"Henry..."
"Don't lie to me."
"Now you tell me: Did you kill Richard?"
"What if I did?"
[SFX: "Dun, dun, duuun!"]
"Ladies and gentlemen..."
"Our fugitive has been on the run for 90 minutes!"
"What I want out of each and every one of is a a hard-target search..."
"Of every gas station, residence, warehouse, farmhouse, hen house, outhouse, and dog house..."
"In that area!"
"Henry, please. No!"
(Nostalgia Critic)
Doing some climbing? Feeling the weight of the world on your shoulders?
Your own son trying to kill you as he's fighting your nephew, turning your perception of reality completely upside down?
Pepperidge Farm: 'Cause your life's really fucked up.
[Spooky music]
[Deep breath, exhale]
ASS!